this is it this is finally this is it
again this is the moment that you've all
been waiting for
cloak has officially launched as of
right now go to cloak brand calm and you
can find all of our previous items back
in stock baby and in addition to that
you've got two brand spanking new items
this beanie and the infamous courtesan
available in two luscious colors the
comfort the fit the nips hey guys my
name is Mark Blair and today marks the
official launch of cloak brand calm and
cloak in general this is it like this is
the day last time if there's anybody
that's confused last time we were
talking about the brand at first we did
a pre-sale we opened up the website but
now is when things actually get moving
and it's exciting it really is it's
exciting to see because this is the day
when all of the work that we've done for
the past two years finally hits the
ground and it's running everybody that
pre-ordered their stuff will be getting
there like getting their new clothes as
early as next week and if you go to the
website right now cloak brand calm you
can start ordering everything that you
didn't get a chance to do before
everything's sold out in like two days
last time and that blew us away we had
no idea that things we're gonna be like
that we thought it was going to be a
slower burn towards the launch day which
is today
but you two guys didn't because you guys
always push past what we expect you to
do you guys always exceed everything
that we could possibly hope for you guys
are so unbelievably supportive of what
we do and that means the world to us
honestly truly that means the world to
us I can't thank you enough for
supporting this new venture of ours and
and we know that this may seem out of
our element for you guys but this is
something that we've been passionate
about for years something we've wanted
something we've assembled a great team
of people for and you guys supported it
I can't say how much that means to us I
cannot overstate how important that
belief is to us because we never want to
betray that trust that you guys put in
us and we always want to make stuff for
you that we're proud to make and that is
the whole point of cloak we wanted make
stuff that we would want to wear we want
to make stuff that we're proud to show
off we want to make stuff that we're
proud to make for you and that's what
we've done and when people first start
getting their things next week I think
you guys are going to be blown away I
cannot wait for you to see it it is
something that we never thought we'd be
able to do and yet we've done it and
it's only because of you guys so thank
you so much I've got nothing else
special to say oh I guess I do we have
new beanies in stock if you go to cloak
brand comm with the launch we've got new
items every time that we want to get
like a restock we want to try to put new
items out as often as we can now this
may be like a couple items every quarter
every few months or so but we will do
what we can when we can we've got a plan
and hopefully we can stick to it but
we've got a plan and in this part of the
plan we've got new beanies available at
cloak brand comm and new quarter zips so
if you go to cloak brand comm or click
the link in the description below you
can get this lovely luscious new cloak
brand quarter
and it's available in black as well so
it's available in gray and black and
down the road hopefully we will be
adding new items sooner than you guys
expect so check in with all the social
media channels for cloak cloak brand on
Instagram and Twitter and just thank you
honestly thank you so much for believing
in us thank you for believing in cloak
thank you for pre-ordering thank you for
supporting us just thank you for being
there when we needed you for believing
in what we believe it so thank you again
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye